a high-profile company is making a
personal push to end a life-shortening
disease ali leforce is a sideline
reporter for cbs sports and the turner
networks for march madness now her
husband is joe smith he is pitched in
more major league games than any other
active player their mission to help
families have babies born free of
huntington's disease that's a hereditary
illness that destroys the brain cells
cbs saturday morning co-host dana
jacobson spoke with them about their
work and their own struggles to have a
child this is such a personal story glad
they're sharing yeah it is really
amazing and they've been very open from
the outside looking in ali and joe's
life to many may seem like a fairy tale
they are certainly a sports power couple
but after joe's mom was diagnosed with
huntington's disease they made the
decision to only have kids through ivf
to make sure that they do not pass on
the disease then in the midst of their
own personal journey they decided to
focus on helping other couples as well
this is the very beginning of our
journey to make our first child together
we have three frozen embryos without
huntington's disease for over three
years
i did it turner sports sideline reporter
ali laforce has been open and candid
about her journey to have a baby
day five blood work using social media
to document the highs bye little friend
and lowe's today was one of the most
emotional
and
really difficult days
including a miscarriage it's not fair if
you only post the good and not the bad
because that's not real life i just
didn't feel right not sharing because i
don't want women to think that
something's wrong with them when there's
nothing wrong with them we're all going
through our own personal journey we all
have struggles the struggle for ally and
her husband joe to have a baby born
without huntington's disease or hd a
genetic condition that causes the
breakdown of nerve cells in the brain
joe lost his grandmother to hd and just
two years ago his mom lee can you
explain what that's like when you think
about having a family that this disease
might be passed on once you live with
somebody that's had it or somebody in
your family has it and you understand
like
how devastating this is like you just
watch people deteriorate within a couple
years and do things that
it is not
them i am
hungry it's like a demon takes over your
mind you know one second you're happy
the next second you're slamming cabinets
and yelling at your loved ones and they
they take it out on the ones they love
the most which is the hardest and then
on top of that they lose their ability
to walk and speak and eat and swallow it
it's the worst there is no cure for
huntington's and kids of parents with
the disease have a 50 percent chance of
getting it joe decided not to test for
the gene that causes hd why did you
decide not to get tested it's tough
there's no treatment there's no cure
like
what am i going to do make it easier
each day one thing within their power
having an hd free baby through an ivf
procedure that implants embryos which
test negative for that hd gene
not a single family should be held back
from preventing their child from having
huntington's disease or even going
through fertility treatments because
money stands in the way it is the heart
behind joe and allie's foundation help
cure hd a non-profit that helps pay for
families to go through the ivf process a
procedure that can cost up to 40
thousand dollars it's not just that your
kids don't have huntington's their kids
will never have honey tents you're
eliminating it from an entire family
line forever which is eradicating a
disease one family at a time in the u.s
there are roughly 41 thousand people
living with hd and more than 200 000 at
risk in just four years aly and joe's
foundation has helped 16 families have
hd free babies families like tracy and
anthony delonzo's it was very exciting
when we
found out that ali and joe were doing
that for us after having two kids
naturally tracy tested positive for hd
do you think
about if symptoms did start soon
what that means for your family are you
able to even process that i think about
it and it feels like a little bit of a
cloud
over you all the time because you never
know when something's gonna hit
the average age is 30 to 50 for symptoms
and i'm 33. she knows
what it most likely looked like for her
and it's really really difficult to see
just always in the back of our mind and
then with any future kids it was like a
huge factor for us in having children
too you rather would not have kids than
pass on this gene right
then they discovered help cure hd
in 2020 they were accepted for a grant
to cover the roughly 20 thousand dollar
cost of having a baby and in september
josiah was born hd free he doesn't know
it but he's not going to have that worry
in his life he might have it for his
family but not for himself and not for
his future family
it's those success stories that fuel
ally and joe
with all these families that you talked
about that you've helped are these now
friendships
and bonds in a way with some of them at
least close with yeah you're getting
closer with some of them bonds which
they say help them stay motivated as
they continue their own journey the man
behind the needle one thing i struggle
with is his happiness i want him to be
happy when i know that we'll have kids
without huntington's disease i know that
if he died tomorrow he would die in
peace knowing that
period
on march 9th ally and joe got one step
closer
that's pregnant right
yes ma'am okay
they are pregnant right now they're very
early along now allie's only six weeks
along right now i just was texting with
her yesterday she's feeling good and the
reason she shares so early because
people normally don't is what she said
in the piece you can't just share the
good this is a whole journey and so
she's taking people along on this
trying to raise awareness because it's
so important to them their foundation i
do want to point out is helpcurehd.org
there you can find out information about
grants if you're interested if you have
it in your family and also fundraising
because they started this with their own
money but they need help this is really
an issue for people and that money goes
to such a tremendous good use i mean
these families have such a devastating
illness and to have a baby who doesn't
have her words of saying eradicating the
disease from her family line one
pregnancy at a time that is unbelievable
the grandfather thanked them for doing
that for keeping his family line going
and he's never forgotten thank you ali
and joe i love when i said to dana do
they have any children danny goes keep
watching keep watching it happened a
couple times
stop talking
[Laughter]
thank you very much